a lot of people have bitched a lot about
this show this season I haven't because
I've been like the hopeful optimist like
I don't think there are enough episodes
to stick the landing but I'm gonna hope
they pull it off at now there's today
also spoiler warning I'm gonna give you
a spoiler warning cuz I'm gonna
straight-up spoil this episode for you
you've been warned before we get started
this episode like all episodes of Game
of Thrones season 8 that I'm talking
about here on my youtube channel are
brought to you by the Stardust at the
Stardust app is a social media app that
lets you react to review movies trailers
TV shows for 30 seconds at a time click
the link below download the Stardust a
follow me yeah Jeremy Jones get your
voice out there also for those of you
who followed me at Jeremy Jones tag me
in your Game of Thrones posts I have
another winner to announce a winner for
them and a friend to fly down to Los
Angeles California for the Game of
Thrones series finale party hoping they
stick the landing to this thing but I
will talk about that more I'll tell you
who the winner is at the end of this
video first guy talking about the
episode okay until now like you can say
what you want about the battle and it
was poorly lit watch Game of Thrones at
night with no lights on so it didn't
bother me point is they hadn't violated
any characters this season until this
point yeah the writing this season had
been weaker than others the writing
actually everything after season four
had been weaker like this is one through
four like masterful anything after
season four it's like finding
entertaining but it's not seasons 1
through 4 oh really it's today made me
go oh internet was right
really there are three things that stand
out so I'm just gonna stick to them for
this video first of all before we get
into it we were told this was gonna be a
big battle it's not a big battle it's a
massacre part of the problem but first
of all the problem problem they'd been
building for a while is the fact that
Tyrion zamore on now Tyrion Lannister
the intellect a brain that cunning the
tactician look coolest one in the show
by far now he's like this supporting
character that sometimes might be smart
other times Varys is smarter than him
most obviously now he is really I feel
like various and tyrion like the role
should have been swapped to you right
now Varys is like Daenerys is not good
for the realm
Tyrion is like I have to hope because
hope against logic that's how I've
always operated I guess I don't know I
don't know why he's like that right now
but the role should have been reversed
it should've been various being like I
feel like she's good for the realm
everything I do is around Tyrion should
have been like I've been around
power-hungry people all my life and she
is it that would have made more sense
but not this Varys
basically tells Tyrion not not her in
turian snitches and then various gets
burned to death by the dragnet snitches
get stitches Tarin what if what next
Jaime Lannister this [ __ ] was stupid -
in last week's episode Jaime Lannister
hooks up with Brienne of Tarth had been
building for a while then he's like
Circe's hateful so am i I need to go
back to her but I was like nah did I
he's just he's lying he's saying that to
push her away so Brianna Tosh would be
cool for him to go and then he's gonna
go there and be like Oh Cersei and then
he's gonna betray her somehow he's gonna
be like the Trojan horse getting through
the gate it made sense no he just he
just went back on everything Jaime
Lannister's what 7 season arc just came
to a screeching halt because he was like
you know what I don't want to grow any
more I want to revert back and I'm gonna
crawl back to her arms stupid like they
could have just kept him in Winterfell
and he could have been like all right
I'm just gonna end up with Brienne of
Tarth I'm just gonna give up this whole
war but no he doesn't hit it and quit it
scenario with Brienne of Tarth goes
right back to Cersei he tries to help
her escape and then the walls look the
ceiling caves in and they both just get
killed embracing each other that's a
violation of his character arc right
there that's just that's dumb I get that
you want to be shocking cuz Game of
Thrones has always been shocking like
the unexpected happens but it's also
laced in good writing at least the
george RR martin [ __ ] was red wedding
shocking no one saw it coming but
everything was still within character
Jaime Lannister just been looking at
[ __ ] it I'm gonna go back with my deck
sister it doesn't make sense to me
that's shocking for the sake of shocking
not shocking but with good writing so
everyone's genuinely shocked
it's like Jaime Lannister stabbed the
Mad King in the back and the writers of
the show stabbed Jaime Lannister in the
back the writers are the King Slayer
Slayer dumb then there's the other thing
where Daenerys is she's just a villain
now at the point King's Landing is
ringing the bell and everyone's is like
alright the fights over you've won
Daenerys is on her dragon like I don't
think so I think we need to roast more
people just go for Cersei Lannister
which she could have just done she
starts cooking all the civilians just
bow just firebombing everybody not the
Queen
gave the order to cut her friend's head
off not to super zombie who swung the
sword who cut her friends head off but
just civilians men women children people
trying to make a living
kids trying to play ash there's a
character turning heel then there's that
at this point she might as well have
been cut from Theon Greyjoy himself
because she is a [ __ ] dick I don't
get it I just don't get the execution
like I've said in my videos about Game
of Thrones Season eight Ella Daenerys is
losing as she's starting to become
thrown hungry and I meant it but I
thought she'd be a little drunk on power
maybe she was putting her ego first ego
above the people and she's unfit to lead
and Jon Snow has to step in and take her
down off the throne but there's a
difference between someone who's a bit
power-hungry putting your ego above the
people and someone who straight up just
massacres a bunch of innocents burning
them to death with a dragon like that's
a line they're making her character
cross and that's a leap that we have to
take to buy it and given where she's
been I can't make the leap that she
would cross that line so I call [ __ ]
on it like I'll give the show this
Daenerys Targaryen has been a bit
hardcore in some of her punishments yeah
but even then I can't recall her showing
blatant disregard for the lives of
innocence and children not just
disregard like making an active effort
to slaughter them that's still a line to
be crossed that's a different kind of
monster and now I don't know where she
just crosses it and now she's worse than
Cersei ever was
Cersei in the entirety of the eight
seasons has never killed as many
innocent people as Daenerys did in this
one episode she just has to die now
that's a lot of innocent people she
slaughtered subtlety people that's what
made this show great subtlety nuanced
now it's just someone who's good gonna
[ __ ] civilians burn them all it's not
just her like her entire army just
started slaughtering people after there
was a surrendered grey worm I liked grey
worm he just lost his girlfriend not me
just slaughtering people he would swear
it Daenerys and her entire army at that
standstill moment just heard a voice in
their heads of Emperor Palpatine being
like execute Oda 66
everyone just [ __ ] snapped and start
slaughtering everyone Daenerys dragons
to pray the fire and everybody really
think that makes sense and since that
didn't happen it's just the writer just
not enough episodes man characters have
just they've just kind of been
we'll see what happens but man a lot of
you saw this coming a mile away I was
maybe but they're not gonna violate
characters entirely and that's how I see
this went down
I feel like Game of Thrones is slowly
getting everyone on the same page where
it's like no this isn't gonna end
smoothly wonder how those are my
thoughts maybe you agree maybe you don't
but that's my review however I did
promise that I was gonna announce a
winner a new winner who won a trip for
them and a friend to go down to Los
Angeles California for the Game of
Thrones series finale party that the
folks at Stardust are putting on this
was chosen at random via a number
generator spend master 77 fate has
chosen you that's a trip for you and a
friend a friend you deem worthy but as a
wise man once said you must choose truth
wisely fate chose you but who you choose
up to you don't worry about flights
they'll pay for it I'm telling you a
good time on their dime it'll be a good
time because we'll all be there we'll
all be hanging out will be laughing
crying bitching screaming so thanks
again for the Stardust folks for
sponsoring these videos next week I'm
gonna be down in Los Angeles for the
finale so you probably won't get my
finale video until Monday I'll do a
starless reaction like that'll be the
quick way to do it I didn't Monday full
video we'll talk about it well go deep
and as next week is the series finale of
Game of Thrones and I'll be in Los
Angeles California announcing winners to
the contest that is done now Congrats to
those of you who have won thank you to
everyone who participated and thank you
to all of you who've been watching these
Game of Thrones videos and any other
videos I do I love y'all but if you're
liking the Stardust app keep it up keep
getting your voice out there like I said
we all have an opinion might as well get
it out there on those Internet's on the
apps of the internet also if bran
doesn't do anything in the next episode
he's really useless especially for the
power he has we'll see right--so Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 5 have you seen
it what did you think about it do you
agree with me or am I being a bit too
harsh do you still think there's hope to
stick this landing whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]